keep going
[Music]
foreign
so uh you're trying you're doing your
giwasa which means you're trying to
transcend form okay you're not trying to
pick form very quickly
okay that that would not be gu wasn't
okay oh you're not trying to uh predict
form that's also not guas okay so it is
very and I'm not going to say it's an
unnecessary phase
but it isn't necessary it is a necessity
that you move past this phase okay so
you're going like this and you're like I
am going to do 10g not yet
I said okay yeah I'm gonna do close
U-Haul
I'm gonna do sumitosh
the
you do have some
live aspect to that in that he doesn't
know what you're going to do so he will
never come in the way a body care would
in kihon noaza like they're all set up
for the sumitosh so I'm gonna do
simiotage and then you know they're all
ready for that back break fall do you
see that
yeah and so you do
you do you have to have some spontaneity
regarding the my that he provided that
rep do you understand yes okay
however
this is not
giwaza you you're picking ahead of time
and if there is any gu in it it's it's
like that long maybe okay so instead
uh
learn to get
off the line not waiting for him
so he's coming in you can see that I
have already moved right
and as I'm already moving I try to tilt
in
I'll I'll always do that I have to tilt
the spine
and then
he will respond to the Tilt however he
wants to whatever he does and that is
where the technique will reveal itself
okay I don't choose the technique I I
let it reveal itself okay so we're going
there's the tilt
check meeting revealed well there's the
tilt
[Music]
tilts
so it doesn't it doesn't ever start from
here
from here
nor does it start from the 12 6 line
okay get off the line tilt
non-contest with how he responds to the
Tilt okay technique will reveal itself
go again
off stop stop
come back
start moving moving move in tilt so that
would be the same technique that's the
same type of training as before
okay come on
move tilt there's the moment
okay you had to pull his arm down so
that was contestation it didn't fit you
picked the technique go
tilt
and there and there you see okay did not
fit
so now we're in G was it do you see
foreign
[Music]
so you expected it to end there yes okay
it does there's no ending because
there's no middle because there's no
narrative it's just an energetic
relationship here we go
[Music]
foreign
again to not fit
[Music]
you see how you had to go backwards so
you went one way then you went the other
way okay
energy keeps going forward
that would be the first type of training
you're going to get off the line tilt
her
and then non-contest
the first type of training
[Music]
do the farm right
so that pause you see oh that's that's
what we're losing okay you want you want
you want to lose that
so I
have to continue
it looks like it's picked from the start
okay uh but as we're going along you see
that he doing something different if you
stay there okay so in this one his
uh stand up try to remember where you
are you're kind of crunched you see but
okay and you broke Center okay on the
last one he had his Center the leg was
up do you think do you get it and so now
now he can turn on that but when his
when he broke Center and he crunched
do you think he can't he's not going to
turn on that do you see that so the
angle's over here now I have to move to
generate the angle
yeah well there's that easy that was the
first one so if he if he does that
reaction there he didn't so he came back
around this way
so it looks like his same thing
hey would you try to do that right here
he's coming around this like but at
least he's coming in at me
so we take it the other way
but it looks like it's seamless because
I
don't know
so you don't see the parts
[Music]
there's that crunch again there's no
there's no technique here that you guys
want to try
because he's so crunchy crunched up and
he's coming at me do you see but a yield
and then it's right here when it happens
boom
that's what you're trying to get at
engine you want
all right